a proposed class action lawsuit against
a major hospice care provider is raising
new questions about who
is an essential employee a california
sales representative who is suing vitas
health care claims managers wanted her
to visit medical facilities despite the
pandemic
she says vitas endangered her and others
by labeling its workers essential
and sending them to nursing homes and
medical offices
consumer investigative correspondent
anna warner has been following the story
anna good morning
good morning jerica yes when many people
when their lives can no longer be saved
many people go into hospice for comfort
care
now someone sells that service but some
say their company
has been too aggressive in selling
during this pandemic
what's happening is wrong
it's putting people's lives in danger
and it needs to stop what christina
eisenacher says
needs to stop are the practices of her
own employer
vitas healthcare the nation's largest
for-profit hospice company
i didn't want to speak out but there was
really no choice
when people's lives are at stake
eisenacher worked as a sales
representative
visiting medical facilities to get
referrals for hospice patients
the role really includes visiting
doctors and educating them
on what the company has to offer but in
mid-march bay area counties issued
shelter-in-place orders due to the
pandemic
so eisenacher says she was surprised
when just a few days later
she got this robo-call from her employer
alvida's staff are considered essential
health care workers
report to work as scheduled governor
state home order does not apply
do you think you were essential no
neither she says did some of her clients
who told her as a salesperson you are
not essential and you have no business
being in a hospital or a doctor's office
right now
so they didn't want you there they
didn't want us there because of that
and her own respiratory problems
eisenacher refused and some
weeks later sued kay van way is
eisennacher's attorney
let's be clear that this is health care
sales
this is not rendering health care
services to patients
yet text messages we obtain show vita
sales people visiting multiple bay area
nursing homes and doctor's offices
during the pandemic
they took numerous selfies with health
care workers
some bringing gifts of pizza chicken or
donuts
under one picture a rep even wrote six
boxes of these made their way into a
local nursing home
that isn't allowing food in from the
outside
a fellow employee texted back sneaky
sneaky
another email shows a manager running a
weekend referral contest
saying whoever gets the most selfies
with medical personnel
could win personnel including nursing
home staff
emergency room staff physicians or
nurses
you know my mom and dad are in their 70s
if it was my parents in one of these
facilities and i had
any idea what this company was doing i
would be outraged
it's not appropriate this former vita
sales rep who did not want to be
identified told us
her managers wanted her to keep visiting
centers with
cancer patients i'm a danger to them
even if i have the flu
i'm a danger to them and so the fact
that they continued to
ask me to do this when it was not in the
best interest
of patients but telling me that it was
was insane it was like living in a
twilight zone she says she tried to get
permission to work from home but later
was fired
vitas would not comment on eisenocker's
case or do an interview
but in a statement it said
representatives work directly with
health care partners to educate them and
support hospice care transitions
our representatives are critical to
ensuring access to hospice care for
health care partners
and thereby hospice eligible patients
making them
essential workers in the health care
system do you believe that this was
about
providing the best care for patients no
because if it was
then why would we be putting patients
lives potentially in danger
so what do you think it was really about
making more money they're in the
business of death
and unfortunately their employees could
have been contributing to more deaths
to their benefit
in a response to the lawsuit filed last
week vita said
it has not violated any law or
regulation and denied the allegations
anthony no
but it does hardly seem essential to
make sales calls during a pandemic anna
thank you very much